a man spent fifteen thousand dollars
on high-tech dog costumes to fulfill his
lifelong dream of and i say this in
quotes becoming a dog that is him in the
costume
that's not a real dog jed you say no
that's him okay so
funny entertaining
also just a tad bit disturbing
i'm gonna read from the article i never
have my papers in order that's something
you need to know about me there's a bit
of chaos that goes in to the dream
all right his nickname is good boy
because why not the man
as a dog
a japanese man is going viral after
spending more than 15k on a
hyper-realistic costume so he could
fulfill his lifetongue dream
of becoming a dog what's interesting is
uh there's no quotations around the word
becoming in this column
from the new york post he didn't become
a dog
let's just say that all right now
he has racked up more than 600 000
youtube views since it was posted and
actually i think it's more i've i
checked it's 1.8 million actually as of
now 1.8 million views
on videos
he actually paid a company called zepit
for those wondering at home who are like
i want to become a dog you can too
15 grand company called zepit makes
costumes for tv commercials and films
you could see how that would work i mean
that could definitely
look real in a tv commercial
final product took 40 days and multiple
revisions imagine comes back with the
door ugh i don't know the paws don't
look quite right
i don't know the teeth
i don't see it i don't see the fangs do
not look real to me go back do it again
can you imagine the revision process
does the tongue stick out far enough
yeah exactly the tail long enough i'm
not feeling enough claw
okay
i've gone too far
anyway if you look at the images maybe
we can go uh tyler i don't know if the
video is in here if you find it while
i'm talking just feel free to play that
video i think the video is in here
somewhere um
i can't see it oh yes it is it is in
here there's a video of of the dog oh
there we go so that's him in the dog
costume
and he he doesn't just look like a dog
he performs as a dog you can see
um very detailed
look he'll
roll over perhaps he takes orders like a
dog i don't know you'd have to ask his
partner i don't know
so
let's establish a few things in this
story first of all
he's not a dog
he's not a dog
2022 you have to say that so he's not
actually a dog he didn't become a dog
but he did dress like a dog
that's point number one you're like ted
why they need to clarify sometimes you
need to clarify it's all i'm gonna say
my second point on this is why do we
feed this stuff
1.8 million views what is it about us as
a society are are we a little sick
think about i mean are we a little is it
curiosity are you like whoa
is it like those tick tock videos where
you see someone take slime and do crazy
things with it and you're just like
for like i don't know three hours is
that what's happening here
what is it that makes us stare at this
stuff because you know that by going and
looking at it and building up views we
encourage it we encourage other people
to to do these things because they're
like well i can make money on youtube
i'm gonna be a cat i'm gonna be a class
that's cat that's not declawed i'm gonna
scratch things up i mean you know people
get ideas from us
from what we endorse
it's funny
in some respects we can all laugh we can
all but then you know five minutes later
we're like the decay of society society
is in decay meantime you spend an hour
watching a man dress as a dog
heal
just saying
all right
the other component of this is something
people don't like to talk about which is
this is a person that's probably not
mentally all there right this is not
can we all just acknowledge that a well
person probably wouldn't now i know you
all have your hobbies
i like to exercise maybe you like to
dress up as a cat i don't know
tyler's just losing it on the other side
but it's true right everybody's got
things they like we all got some weird
quirks out there but i think we can all
agree that if you spend fifteen thousand
dollars and go through a full series of
revisions on a dog costume to look like
a dog
something may not be adding up
okay now this can get serious though it
can get very serious because i don't
know if you guys remember catman
catman was a guy who
wanted to become a cat
and got multiple surgeries i don't know
if you have that article tyler if i gave
you that one okay
i forget what i give tyler knight before
catman the human tiger who enjoys
climbing trees and eats raw meat every
day in that article this is what it says
as obsession this is old but it's
important that's images as i'm reading
as obsessions go this has to be one of
the weirdest known to man someone who
would voluntarily file his teeth split
his lip and undergo extensive facial
surgery to turn himself into a human
tiger
his body modification operations
included splitting of his upper lip
surgical pointing of the ears silicone
cheek and forehead implants tooth filing
tattoos and facial piercing to which
whiskers
were in fact attached
he ate as close to raw as possible or at
the temperature that an animal would be
if it had just been killed obviously
we don't eat like that you know that's
not
okay
now the very disturbing part of this and
the very sad part about this is he died
he died in 2012 of an apparent suicide
as it was reported
he was not a well person right this was
someone who was struggling with
something that was going on
um and i remember at the time that this
cat man gained an incredible amount of
fame i remember seeing a bunch of media
reports
television like you just people just
wanted to spotlight him because it was
it was odd and it was interesting they
were like oh clickbait clickbait people
will watch all the media cares about
it's like oh clickbait clickbait
everything is clickbait oh what can i do
to get it doesn't matter if it causes
the demise of a human or society that's
secondary or tertiary to these people
but nobody wanted to say the truth which
was that this was a person who was in
need of psychological help and there was
something there was something wrong
he was not going to become a cat
this man is not going to become a dog
and the reason i bring this up is
because we are in a time now where truth
has ceased to matter to many people on
many issues i don't care if it's obesity
and i don't care if it's and the risks
associated with that and i don't care if
it's a gen a conversation about gender
and biological men and biological women
in sports and trans men in women's sport
i don't care what the topic is the truth
has ceased to matter and people just now
invent
they just invent
and they demand that you comply and no
one can ask real questions like is this
healthy
is this sane
is this person in need of help what is
going on you're not allowed to do those
things or you are flagged as as i said
before fatphobic transphobic all the
phobics they're everywhere they're
coming to get you
and it's growing it's growing it's
growing and the result is going to be a
population that suffers
it's going to be a population that
suffers without proper help and it's
going to be a population if you cease to
to acknowledge truth in different areas
and the truth seems to i mean then
everything just dissipates right
everything is if everything is
subjective
then there is no fact there's nothing
tangible to adhere to in society it's
like people who say oh reminds me of the
conversation about the constitution it's
living and breathing what does that mean
what does that mean
it is what you need it to be on a
tuesday no that's not gonna work for me
facts are facts end of story i'm tired
of catering to this madness
people suffer as a result of catering to
this madness i'm done if you like the
short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]